[Music]
my name is John kzi and I work on a team
at Jane Street called AI assistant our
group roughly uh is there at Jan Street
to try to maximize the value that Jan
Street can get from large language
models and I've spent my entire career
uh in Dev tools before I worked at Jan
street I was a GitHub for a long time
and then before that I worked at a
variety of other Dev tools companies and
llms kind of present this really amazing
opportunity in that they're so
open-ended that we can build kind of
anything that we can imagine and it
seems like right now the only thing
moving faster than the progress of the
models is kind of our creativity around
how to employ them uh at Jan street
though we've made some choices that make
adoption of off-the-shelf tooling a
little bit more difficult than it is for
other companies
and kind of the biggest reason that we
have this problem is that we use o camel
as a development platform for those not
familiar with oaml it is a a functional
very powerful language but it's also
incredibly obscure language uh it was
built in France and its most common
applications are in things like theorem
proving or formal verification it's also
used to write programming
languages um we use oaml kind of for
everything at change
so just a couple quick examples when we
write web applications of course web
applications have to be written in
JavaScript but instead we write oaml and
we use a library called JS of oaml that
is essentially a oaml bik code to
JavaScript
transpiler when we write plugins for Vim
those have to be written in Vim script
uh but we actually use a library called
vaml which again is oaml to vimscript
transpiler and uh even people at the
company that are working on fpga code
they're not writing verog they're
writing in an O camel Library called
hard
camel uh so why are the tools on the
market available not good for working
with oaml I think it kind of comes down
to a few primary reasons the first and
the most important is that models
themselves are just not very good at
oaml and this isn't the fault of the AI
labs this is just kind of a byproduct of
the amount of data that exists for
training so it's there's a really good
chance that the amount of okl code that
we have inside of J street it's just
more than like the total combined amount
of oam code that there exists in the
world uh outside of our
walls the second is that we've made
things really hard on ourselves
partially as a byproduct of working in O
camel we've had to build our own build
systems we built our own distributed
build environment we even built our own
code review system which is called
iron we develop all of our software on a
giant monor repo application and just
for fun instead of storing that monor
repo in git we store it in mercurial
and uh at last count 67% of the firm
uses emac instead of normal editors
maybe like vs code uh we do have people
using vs code but emac is the most
popular and the last thing is we're
dreamers I mean kind of everyone in this
room hopefully is is a dreamer in a way
uh and what I mean by this is we want
the ability to kind of take llms and
apply them to different parts of our
development flow and light up different
parts so maybe we want to use large
language models to resolve merge
conflict or build better feature
descriptions or figure out who reviewers
for features be and we don't want to be
hampered by the boundaries between
different systems when we do
that over the next 15 minutes I'm going
to cover our approach to large language
models at CH Street uh particularly when
it comes to developer tools um I'm going
to talk about custom models that we're
building and how we build them I'm going
to talk about editor Integrations so
these are the Integrations into uh to vs
code emac and neovim
and I will talk about uh the ability
that we've built over time to evaluate
models and figure out how to make them
perform
best and I guess at first glance it's
not really obvious that training models
at all is a good idea I mean it's very
expensive proposition it takes a lot of
time and it can go wrong in a ton of
different ways who here has trained a
model before or tried to train something
like a model maybe took a foundation
model and trained on top of
it
cool we were more convinced after we
read this paper this is a paper from
meta about a project called code compose
and in this paper they detail their
results fine tuning a model specifically
for use with hack uh hack is actually
pretty similar to O camel uh not in its
like syntax or function but really just
in the fact that it's used primarily at
one company and not really used much
outside of that company even though it's
open source so oh actually a fun fact
hack is implemented in no camel I think
that's just like a total coincidence
but uh we were pretty naive early on we
read this paper and we decided that it
would be really cool if we could
replicate the results we thought we
would just take a model off the shelf we
would show it a bunch of our code and
then we would get back a model that uh
worked like the original model but knew
about our libraries and
idioms it turns out that's just not how
it works uh it's not that easy in order
to get good outcomes you have to have
the model see a bunch of examples that
are in the shape of the type of question
that you want to ask the model so we
needed to First create a goal a thing
that we wanted the model to be able to
do and in our in our world the goal that
we came up with was this we wanted to be
able to generate diffs given a prompt so
what that means is we wanted a user
inside of an Editor to be able to write
a description of what they wanted to
happen and then have the model suggest a
potentially multifile diff so maybe you
want to modify the test file an ml file
and an mli which is kind of like a
header
file we wanted the diffs to apply
cleanly and we wanted them to have a
good likelihood of typechecking after
they had been applied and we were kind
of targeting this range of up to 100
lines as an ideal zone of what we
thought llms would actually be capable
of and in order for that to work we
needed to collect data like I was
talking about before we needed data of
the training shape that looked just like
the test shape and this is what that
shape looks like for this task you need
to be able to collect a bunch of
examples of what context the model would
have had beforehand and then some prompt
of what you want the model to do written
hopefully in the same way that a human
would write it and then some diff that
would accomplish that goal so context
prompt diff and we need a bunch of these
examples so how do we get these how do
we get these training
examples kind of the first place to look
is features features is I mentioned a
code review system that we built
internally this is what it looks like
it's called iron uh features are very
similar to poll requests I think you can
just you know swap that term in your
head and features at first glance have
exactly the data they want on the
description tab they have a human
written description of a change and on
the diff tab they have the code that
accom is the goal of the
developer but on closer look they're not
exactly what you want right the way that
you write a feature description or a p
request description is really very
different from what you might want to
say inside of an editor so you're not
writing multiple paragraphs in the
editor you're just saying something like
fix that error that's happening right
now and that's just not how we write
feature descriptions another problem
with these features or P requests is
that they're really large right often
it's a feature is 500 lines or a
thousand lines so in order to use it as
training data we would need to have an
automated way to pull features apart
into individual smaller components that
we could train
on so we need smaller things than
features what are those well maybe
commits commits are smaller chunks than
features uh this is what a typical
commit log looks like at Jan street so
this is not like a git short log this is
literally just like an actual I want you
to look at this as an actual git log and
where it says summary Z that's my commit
message we don't really use commits the
same way the rest of the world use
system so we use commits mostly As
checkpoints between different parts
parts of a development cycle that you
might want to revert back to commits
don't have a description and they also
have the same problem in that they're
not isolated changes they're they're a
collection of changes what we actually
ended up with was a approach called
workspace snapshotting and the way that
that works is we take snapshots of
developer workstations throughout the
workday so you can think like every 20
seconds we just take a snapshot of what
the developer doing and as we take the
snapshots we also take snapshots of the
build status so the build that's running
on the box we can see what the error is
or whether the build is green and we can
kind of notice these little patterns if
you have a green to Red to Green that
often corresponds to a place where a
developer has made an isolated change
right you start writing some code you
break the build and then you get it back
to green and that's how you make a
change maybe this one the red to Green
this is the place where the developer
encountered an error whether that's a
type error or a compilation error and
then they fixed it so if we capture the
build error at the Red State and then
the diff from red to Green we can use
that as training data to help the model
be able to recover from
mistakes the next thing we need is a
description and the way that we did that
we just used the large language model so
we had a large language model write a
really detailed description of a change
in in as much words as it possibly could
and then we just kept filtering it down
until it was something that was around
the right level of what a human would
write so now we have this training data
and training data is kind of only half
the picture of training a model so you
you have the the supervised training
data and then you need to do the second
part which is the reinforcement learning
this is really where models get a lot of
their power right we we align the
model's ability to what humans think is
actually good code so what is good code
I guess on the surface good code is I
mean it's it's code it has the parse is
code meaning if a piece of code doesn't
go through the O camel parser and come
out with a green status that is that is
not good code I would say by most
definitions
uh good code in oaml because it's
statically typed is code that type
checks so we want to have good code be
code that when it is applied on top of a
base revision can go through the type
Checker and the type Checker agrees that
the code is
valid and of course the the gold
standard is that good code is code that
compiles and passes tests so ideally in
during the reinforcement learning phase
of a model you could give the model a
bunch of tasks that are like verifiable
we have the model performs some some
edit and then we check whether or not it
actually passes the test when applied to
the
code so we did that uh we've done this
as part of our our training cycle and we
built this thing that is called uh CES
it's the code evaluation service you can
think of it kind of like a build service
except with a slight modification to
make it much faster and that's that
first we pre-warm a build it sits at a a
revision and is green and then we have
these workers that all day just take
diffs from the model they apply them and
then we determine whether the build
status turns red or green and then we
report that error or or success back up
to the build function and through
continued use of this service over the
course of like months we're able to
better align the model to write code
that actually does compile and past
tests it turns out this exact same setup
is the one that you would want for
evaluation so if you just hold out some
of the RL data you can also use it to
evaluate model's ability to write code
kind of looks like this you give the
model a problem you let it write some
code and then you evaluate whether or
not the code that it writes actually
works and training is hard and it can
have kind of uh catastrophic but
hilarious results so at one point we
were training a code review model and
this is a totally separate model but the
idea was we want to be able to give some
code to this model and have it do a
first passive code review just like a
human would do to try to save some of
the toil of of code review we train this
model we put a bunch of dat dat into it
we worked on it for months we're real
excited and we put our first code in for
uh for code review through the automated
agent it spun for a bit and it came back
with something along the lines of um
I'll do it
tomorrow and like of course it did that
because it's trained on a bunch of human
examples and humans write things like
I'll do things or I'll do this tomorrow
uh so it's it's you know not very
surprising so having evaluations that
are meaningful is kind of a Cornerstone
of making sure that models don't go off
the rails like this and you don't waste
a bunch of your time and
money in the end though the real test of
models is whether or not they work for
humans so I'm going to talk a little bit
about the editor Integrations that we've
built to expose these models to
developers at Jan
Street kind of when we were starting
building these Integrations we had three
ideas in mind the first idea was wow we
support three editors we have neovim vs
code and emac and we really don't want
to write the same thing three times so
ideally we don't want to write all the
same context building strategies and all
of the same prompting strategies we want
to just write at once the second is that
we wanted to maintain flexibility so we
had a model that we were using at the
time uh that was not a fine tuned model
we were pretty convinced that a fine
tuned model was in our future we wanted
the ability to do things like swap the
model or swap the prompting strategy out
and lastly we wanted to be able to
collect metrics so in a developer uh in
their in their editor developers care
about latency and they care about
whether or not the diffs actually apply
so we wanted to get kind of on the
ground real experience of whether or not
the diffs really were meaningful for
people this is the simplified version of
the architecture that we settled on for
this service the AI development
environment essentially you have llms on
one side and then Aid handles all of the
uh ability to construct prompts and to
construct context and to see the build
status and then we are able to just
write these really thin layers on top of
Aid uh for each of the individual
editors and what's really neat about
this is that Aid sits as a sidecar
application on the Developers machine
which means that we when we want to make
changes to Aid we don't have to make
changes to the individual editors and
hope that people restart their editors
we can just restart the Aid Service on
all of the boxes so we restart Aid and
then everyone gets the most recent
copy uh this is an example of Aid
working inside of vs code so this is the
sidebar in vs code very similar to
something like co-pilot except this
thing allows you to uh ask for it and
get back multifile diffs uh and you can
see it kind of looks like what you'd
expect in VSS code it's it's you know a
visual interface that lays things out
really
nicely this is what we built in emac
though so in emac developers are used to
working in text buffers they move around
files they want to be able to copy
things the normal way that they copy
things so we actually built the eight
experience in emac into a markdown
buffer so users can move around inside
this markdown buffer they can ask
questions and then there are key binds
that essentially append extra content to
the bottom of the markdown
buffer AIDS architecture lets us plug
various pieces in and out like I
mentioned uh so we can swap in new
models we can uh make changes to the
context building we can add support for
new editors which I think probably
sounds far-fetched but this is something
we're actually just doing right
now uh and we can even add domain
specific tools so different areas of the
company can supply tools that are
available inside of the editors and they
kind of end up in all the editors
without having to write individual
Integrations eight also allows us to AB
test different approaches so we can do
something like send 50% of the company
to one model and 50% to another and then
determine which one gets the higher
acceptance rate a is kind of a an
investment that pays off over time every
time something changes in large language
models we're able to change it in one
place Downstream of the editors and then
have it available
everywhere and things change like really
often and we need to be ready uh when
things change what I what I've had time
to show you today is only a small
portion of what my team is doing we've
got a lot of other things going on so
we're finding new ways to apply rag
inside of the editors we're applying
similar approaches to what you've seen
here to large scale uh multi-agent
workflows we are working with reasoning
models more and more but the approach is
the same through all of these we keep
things pluggable we lay a strong
Foundation to build on top of and we
build the ways for the rest of the
company to add to our experience by
adding more domain specific tooling on
top of it
uh if you think what I've said is
interesting and you want to talk more
about this I would love to hear from you
you can just find me outside and thank
you for your time
[Music]
[Applause]